[Music]
megalo plays the Rwandan capital Kigali
the track Jesse Owens pays tribute to
the african-american sprinter who won
four golds at the 1936 Olympic Games
held in Nazi Germany but most of the
rapper's current album is actually about
Africa and now he's there himself
this trip was planned a long time ago
before I finished the album we released
it later than expected we'd wanted the
videos to come out in summer because
their summer hits but it took longer
politics the music industry so it came
out just before this trip but that's
good because we can share it with people
here directly Nigerian roots is touring
the continent with his producer gun knee
and stallion they're now in Rwanda after
a stint in Uganda and will also be
performing in Kenya the Democratic
Republic of Congo and Zimbabwe
performing and also doing workshops with
other musicians theatre Institute
compiled the varied programme which will
enable the two Germans to get an insight
into very different worlds it's really
interesting it's different here from
Kampala for instance that's really a
cultural hub one of the best places for
going out in Africa Kigali is a bit
different at least that's my first
impression I'm excited about what else
we're going to see during this trip was
the hosting trip use in today's workshop
takes place at the Music High School in
ki Ando three hours away from Kigali
the workshop was organized by katarina
hey the head of the Goethe Institute in
Kigali megalo got to know the students a
bit talking about all sorts of things
from the difficulties musicians have in
Germany to family problems and record
companies finally it was time for some
music
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
then megalo showed the music students
what he could do to with a spontaneous
part of rapping and rhyming
we're gonna do four uncommon dealings a
Dingman we don't want to turn up here
like a glue fo and do our thing exchange
we want Germany and local culture to
come into contact in common this
workshop was a perfect example new Luca
team had an imperfect the Spanish
there's so much freedom when it comes to
music here but I must admit it was tough
for me to rap to an unfamiliar beat ie
to traditional Rwandan African music it
wasn't normal for for time and I had to
get away from my German understanding of
music but it was a lot of fun and opened
me up to new experiences
nobody knows Vox novice Adso fish pasta
Martin of God flee to annoy or foul
today
megalo and Ghanaian stallion are
performing in a poor district of Kigali
they deliberately chose this venue to
make their music more accessible and
they have a message for the audience
long live Africa
you
[Music]